it's Gotham nobody ever stays dead
[Music]
that's old corpse the latest episode of
Gotham episode 19 of season 4 so yes
spoil is pretty much right off the bat
Rachele ghoul is back of a Roz that
pronounce it Roz in the spike aunt after
the episodes ends I can never remember
in this weather they're pronouncing it
Rea sure Roz uh in any case he's back
the ghoul guy he's back and zombified
her big chug abyss and I suppose it was
inevitable that he was gonna come back
because coming back from the dead is
kinda his whole shtick but I'm still a
little bit irritated and frustrated I
mentioned you know back when he first
showed up at the start of this season
that I didn't really like his inclusion
inclusion in this show it feels like a
bad fit it feels like the wrong end of
Batman's stuff because you know we've
had absolute insanity on the show and I
love it but when it comes to the really
Outlander stuff it's all been Mad
Science it's never been mystical cultish
supernatural stuff it's always had a
very flimsy pseudo-scientific
explanation whether it was Hugo Strange
or even even I be you know gulping down
this you know weird herbal concoction
yogi that's still close enough but now
we've literally got a guy coming back to
life because of a ritual and I don't I
don't love it I don't feel like that
that fits Gotham and what Gotham is that
said I I kind of wish he'd stayed as a
zombie because him as a zombie I kind of
dug more and that's not a knock on the
performance not I'm not I'm the actor
you place the parts fine I'm just I'm
just not loving him in this there is
still some good stuff in here though I'm
actually I'm increasingly intrigued by
the relationship between Lea and Ed or
Lea and the Riddler or
leann dead and the Riddler first of all
I really like the Riddler look in the
mirror and getting the same treatment
that he'd been giving at all that time
you know machi ad in the mirror now
Ed's mocking him like that was that's
such a simple like almost ad of course
you'd do that but I'm like that's that's
clever
I do enjoy that and I find it
interesting that with Lee and and Edie
that Ed does not have it's not an idiot
he doesn't have an illusion that she's
not using him he knows that but he's
still willing to go along with that I
that's a relationship that I find
intriguing someone who is aware of the
imbalance of the relationship but stays
anyways that is that is interesting to
me and Lee has been fairly interesting
this entire season ever since she got
infected last year it's I've really
enjoyed her the stuff with Barbara was a
little bit of a mix I'm not I'm I'm not
upset that she lost the demons head
because as I said before her sort of
going down that path just it didn't
bring out what I loved about Barbara
which is nuts but she still has some
good moments the the visualization of
the demons had sort of giving the the
visions it seemed in the future was
actually really well done starting with
her getting stabbed and then it's kind
of reminding and then she dodges stuff
and then it actually you know just shows
her dodge the next few moves ooh and you
think oh they were just gonna show it
that one time to establish how it works
and that's how she's continuing to do
well in this fight but then tabby gets
her throat cut and you know you think oh
wow I didn't expect them to go that
every wines a little again and normally
I call that you know a cheap trick but I
think it I think it's actually played
well I think I think the way in which is
presented and the pacing of it and the
points at which it it you know gives you
a little bit of the rug pull I I think
that played out really well I was
surprised that worked as well as it did
I was a little disappointed by Oswald
and Grundy cuz they were just kind of
there
I'm assuming like them getting betrayed
by Ed is gonna set up something for
later except we've done Edie and and
penguin betraying each other before so I
don't know what there is to do I feel
like I feel like oz both hasn't had a
real shining moment this season aside
from his choice to appear to blow up
Martine
since then he's just kind of been around
I don't know so you know that was that I
wasn't especially great I know the other
thing I'll give credit for with with
Ra's al Ghul is that I do like that they
are continuing to draw the the the line
in terms of how much that screwed up
Bruce to kill him and just because he
not really but he appeared to get over
it since that happened you know would
time and damage but that he you can see
it's sort of pulling that out of him
again just being confronted with this
man and the possibility of having to
kill him again
that that feels right that feels well
played Selena uh uh you can I think she
does a really good job of showing the
the pull that she's feeling between her
friends and Bruce and like in her mind
there isn't a reason she shouldn't be
able to have both because these aren't
people who are who have a reason to
always be butting heads but they keep
doing it and then she has to choose
sides and you can tell she doesn't want
to do that I like how that works that
that plays well I think that's about it
it's actually you know having talked it
out it's a better episode than I thought
I was gonna say it was cuz it does have
quite a bit of stuff I like I just don't
like that Ra's al Ghul is back that's
today and unfortunately that's sort of
the big you know takeaway from this
episode that's our big lasting and here
we go my dang it
just cuz like I said I think he's the
wrong fit and you know he was he was
really good for the animated series he
was really good for Batman Begins where
they sort of debunk to the fantastical
elements of it here it just doesn't feel
right
and maybe I'm the only one who feels
that I don't know but in any case lady
this episode of Gotham pretty good I'm
concerned how long they're gonna be
stretching out there Ra's al Ghul stuff
but we'll see
so have you seen it what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like can subscribe if follow
me on Twitter support me on patreon
links for all that stuff and more is
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]